alice a catholic teenager forced to live
in chastity until marriage starts a chat
conversation that leads her to discover
her sexuality today on cinema recapped
i'll show you
yes
god yes the movie begins with a girl
named alice who is in a school
administered by the church there we see
a teacher who is very strict with all
the students
especially the girls who annoy her by
wearing short skirts this teacher runs
into our protagonist but she only tells
her that there will soon be a mass and
asks for her to support it since alice
is considered a very pure girl later a
father is explaining the changes that
happen during puberty
some students ask him about touching
themselves to which he responds that
they should not do it since they should
keep themselves for marriage and if not
they will be eternally damned because
god is always watching them then one of
alice's friends named laura is very
upset because she was in another class
where they were taught about motherhood
but since she still hasn't slept with
anyone she says they shouldn't give such
silly lessons
later alice is at her home eating some
snacks and then she goes to her computer
to answer some surveys about movies and
anonymous chats however someone in the
chat sends her an email where he
attaches some adult photos
the girl gets scared and quickly changes
the window since she had never seen such
a thing in her life
then she makes sure that no one is at
home
opens the mail again and begins to look
at the photos with curiosity the person
in the chat sends her some messages
where he asks if she's touching herself
alice doesn't know what he means
so she looks in the mail and sees a
photo of another girl doing it then
alice tries it and starts discovering
the pleasures of that part of her body
something she'd never experienced but at
that moment her mother yells at dinner
is ready the next day alice gets into a
car with some of her friends
they question the rumors that she was
with a boy named wade with whom she was
supposedly doing adult activities in a
sauna alice quickly denies such rumors
saying that she doesn't even like that
boy
however later on we see that she
actually looks very interested in wade
at breakfast alice is with laura when
another girl named beth tells her that
everyone knows about her and wade
but our protagonist prefers to ignore
such comments
beth says that she was at a school
retreat called kierkos where they gave
her a medal for participating
then another girl tells beth that it's
time to eat
they leave to sit together at another
table
later alice runs into wade and his
girlfriend named heather who stare at
her without saying anything since they
believe that she started the rumors
our protagonist makes an innocent
comment about milk but they interpret it
like an adult reference and leave saying
she's disgusting
during a mass the teacher no longer
wants alice to support her since she's
heard the rumors and also tells the girl
to respect herself and not hang out with
the boys
alice is surprised that the rumors have
gone this far and she also notices that
wade loves heather very much
and that she's also part of kirikos
since she wears a locket from there
later alice goes with the father to
confess
but she doesn't dare tell him about what
she did in front of the computer nor
about the messages and photos she saw on
it
then while doing penance she remembers
the kirikos retreat
she thinks it's convenient to join and
improve her life
a few days later alice and laura enter
the retreat traveling in a truck
directly to the event
when they arrive they see a very
handsome boy named chris who is an
american football star and also part of
kyrgos
a girl named nina welcomes alice since
they will be in the same cabin
she follows her and they enter their
rooms
nina tells her that they can't have
watches or cell phones but our
protagonist hides her phone and just
hands over her watch
the next day they gather everyone into
groups and alice gets to meet chris who
kindly welcomes her to the team
then the father welcomes everyone to the
event telling them that it will be
unforgettable and it will make them
improve as people some sheets are passed
around in which they will describe what
their feelings are selecting them from a
list
alice selects several and notices that
among the options there's the word
horny
and after thinking about it for a bit
she decides to select it alice turns
around and notices that she is one of
the first to finish
she reflects a little on the options she
selected
and decides to erase it but the pencil
eraser does not work correctly and she
cannot remove what she marked
they asked them to deliver the sheets of
paper so our protagonist just checks the
option and hands it over to the teacher
later alice runs into chris at breakfast
and we see that the girl is very
interested in the beauty of the boy's
hands
then nina tells a few sad stories that
happened to her in the past
the situation becomes moving and several
teammates hug her so she doesn't feel
alone
that night alice can't sleep and decides
to take her cell phone and play a little
bit
but when she wins the device makes a
very loud sound so she puts it on
vibration
then the girl has an idea about the
vibration mode and decides to put it
down there
enjoying how it makes her feel
the next day they all go to the woods
where alice pretends to fall by accident
only for chris to pick her up and take
her to the infirmary
she enjoys being carried by him
later nina enters our protagonist room
and tells her that they will soon take a
group photo
at that moment alice receives some
messages and nida discovers the hidden
device
nida tells her that she will tell the
father about it alice gets sad since her
naughty toy will be taken away from her
when they take the photo some boys
bother her since they still believe the
rumors about her and wade
at the end of the photo session the
father scolds her for the cell phone and
his penance sends her to a nun who gives
her various housework to keep the place
clean
however alice sees a computer and
decides to sneak back into the chat and
start asking about naughty things she's
heard
but she doesn't know what they mean
so anonymous men in the chat explain
those things in great detail and the
girl gets surprised then she hears
noises of someone approaching she turns
off the screen and also pushes the
computer's power button but it does not
turn off
later alice's group gets together and
chris has them to tell a sad story about
themselves
so one by one they tell their anecdotes
when it's alice's turn
she tries to move chris so she invents a
sad story about an imaginary dog that
she lost
another girl starts crying because it
really happened to her so the boy hugs
her while alice gets very envious
the father tells everyone that he
discovered that someone was on his
computer using it to join anonymous
internet chats where they talked about
many sins
he tells them that there's no way to
know who did it although god knows
later the father talks alone with each
of the young people
he asks alice why she underlined the
word horny in the listing and the girl
doesn't know what to say while the man
pressures her to be honest about her
feelings
he also mentions that he knows about
what she did with wade but the girl
denies everything
even so the father tells her that if she
wants girkos to help her she has to be
sincere and not commit any more sins
later wade asked alice for explanations
of the rumors but the girls say she
didn't start them and asked him to
please deny that lie so that everyone
knows the truth
although the boy does not seem
interested in helping her
the father arrives and interrupts them
since he has things to talk about with
wade when they leave alice notices that
the boy left a bracelet which has the
name of his girlfriend heather
later alice is mopping the floor when
she notices that nina is secretly
kissing a boy
but not only that
they do other things which turn on our
protagonist
she begins to touch herself with the mop
although the nun arrives and the girl
leaves the place
alice tells what she saw to laura who
doesn't believe her at all and tells her
that she's ashamed to be her friend
since she's a liar and also did bad
things with wade
later alice is cleaning the sink and
sees the computer again
she puts the bracelet with heather's
name under the keyboard to frame wade
but then she hears the father
approaching and hides
she sees the father display adult videos
on his computer and start touching
himself
the girl can't believe it but she stays
silent so he doesn't discover her
later ellis manages to leave the room
runs into chris and starts to kiss him
since she's very turned on but the boy
gets scared and runs away
that night the father and the others are
singing a nice song while alice decides
to leave since she knows that many of
them do bad things but they continue to
live their lives as if they hadn't done
anything wrong
she enters a bar where she asks for a
drink
at the same time another woman tells her
that she was once fearful and that she
thought she would go to hell for
everything they open up to each other
and alice feels calmer
the next day alice sees the laura's with
nina and other girls so she sits at a
table where there's only one other girl
who always eats alone
at the same time the father takes weight
away since he found the bracelet under
the computer
later the father encourages them to come
forward and say something sincerely
alice stands in front of everyone and
says that people create rumors that hurt
people
but that everyone must learn to manage
their secrets well and not judge others
since everyone hides things
they go back home after finishing their
retreat
a few days later the girl is confessing
to the father again and lets him know
that she saw what he did that day in
front of the computer
she asked him if god would punish her
for seeing that
the father tells her that this is
between god and her and he looks
embarrassed while he gives her his
penance
later the girl arrives home and puts a
movie on television
while she begins to do her thing she
sees a vibrating massager and starts
using it since now she feels that she
can do that kind of thing without
remorse
the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
recaps of the best comedy movies thanks
for watching